hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to oxygen not included
we're still we're still in the same boat
where we were but I'm trying my best
today to just get their stress down
because these guys all these poor guys
in poor Lenny jeez and he's died right
where everyone has to go take a [ __ ]
that's just this is not good so what
we're gonna do is eventually we're gonna
dig the slime we got more algae they're
gonna build a tasteful memorial try to
prioritize that I guess and then
hopefully there's gonna be some options
for these guys to do this it's it's so
bad though because the second that I
repair anything they destroy it this is
the very second I repair something they
destroy it which is making it nearly
impossible Oh Stacey is sad oh my god
they're instantly all painting jeez oh
wow that's damn crude painting that's
okay though you did what you could
it's not helping a lot but you did what
you could these are broken - it's all
broken food beyond reach
and also just not enough oxygen across
the board okay so we gotta focus now we
gotta focus because if we don't we're
gonna die so we got to get this slime
because it's something it's something it
is something so the bio distillery is
gonna make the slime we got to
prioritize building this wall so we
don't die they keep cutting the power
every single time I'm just sorry I'm
gonna try to connect these two power
sources because then at least I can
repair this one and hopefully repair
that battery and ignore the algae
deoxidizer for now well I probably need
one be nice just to have one
okay so that's gonna be sealed off those
are gonna be dug out whenever they get
to that they've got other priorities at
the moment but that's gonna be Doug how
did you get stranded there Josie
damn it how did you get stranded there
Jesus God okay fine then all right so
you got the slime slime Zin there slimes
in there that's gonna produce
contaminated oxygen I know but it's also
gonna run off contaminated water we're
getting slime slime is gonna turn into
algae we'll be able to algae these up
we'll be able to have this deoxidizer
going hopefully anyway okay all right so
someone's carving up there that's good I
guess
these are broken because they have no
power the mush bars aren't running
breaking the batteries of course this is
broken that's being repaired that's
being repaired that's been dug out good
we've got algae going okay but Lisa's
something so now that this is going on
we're getting algae which at the very
least is something that is like
something that we desperately need and I
know I know it is very much know it is
and obviously this is filling up with
contaminated oxygen I know I know that
it's bad we'll do what we can that's why
we got an airlocks like getting both of
them that generator is going the algae
is going we're good
Algie gotta get more fixing what we can
cuz everyone keeps breaking it but
that's okay I can't blame it I'm just
trying to fight stress so what we need
is we need we need some sort of medicine
because these guys health are probably
very low now their health is okay the
decor is down of course the decor is
down what I also need to do is I need to
make storage stuff just so we can clean
this [ __ ] I have someplace to put stuff
new person all right bring them in eh eh
all right wait a level-8 chef with
gastro phobia that can't cook great
that's exactly what we needed in this
environment that's exactly what's gonna
help us that is everything that we need
flatulence all right cool Doris the
farter I'll take Doris the farter some
love get in here with me less stress oh
great of course as soon as the algae
deoxidizer is up and running you have to
beat it up dan dan why why Daniel just
why all right so at least they're making
food at least food is getting made if
not there then let's try to keep it
going up here repair repair repair
repair repair repair repair just repair
whoa abstract structure crude mediocre
scrubbed sugar quaint mmm okay then
are you breaking okay you can break the
batteries just don't break the essential
things ice we got to get that thing
Algie but for some reason these aren't
pumping is because they don't have
enough slime do they need more slime cuz
I can do that like that's easy enough
oh I just realized I can make a priority
9 dig so what we eventually need is to
kind of just build upwards I guess but
[ __ ] the water supply god dammit the
water okay so we need to build a ladder
down to here oh god damn it oh [ __ ] me
Jesus oh god dammit I have a leak
I had a leak this whole time oh no oh no
no contaminated i/o contaminated oxygen
was getting in the whole time shitty
dicks okay well just gonna have some
scrubbers at the ready Oh God all right
well priority up alright I know I could
start over and it would be easier but I
am NOT giving up on my family
everything seems bad and everything is
in crisis but I will not give up on them
I say as they vomit again but I won't
give up I'm gonna see this through I'm
gonna save them no matter what I'm gonna
save them good now that's sealed off
finally I can't believe I was just
letting that leak in this whole time all
my beautiful gas permeable just went to
[ __ ] didn't it
anyway that's gonna filter that out
hopefully in time that'll deodorize it
damn it I wasn't paying attention as of
lashing out
daddy's repair see it's so hard to make
progress now because there's so many
people that are just dedicating their
time to repairing like these haven't
even been able to be repaired just
because everyone's been focused over
here so
there's been a big problem it probably
do me a lot of good to connect the wires
from here to here cuz that way at least
it'll all be in one big chunk and
hopefully these can power that and then
not everything is just on a constantly
deadly system hey at least they're
breathing well because they've got
contaminated oxygen so that's a thing
you know I'm not gonna do this cuz so
I'm just gonna prioritize the cable
connections here god I do not know why
those why in the world are the slimes
not being God I need to make them I have
to make that way don't all right let's
bring another one into the fold
Oh body builder huh that's probably
gonna help yeah sure why not
maja the body builder okay so those are
now connected so at least the grid is
connected and everything is sharing
power but that means that we're gonna
need a lot more power but hopefully I
have a cold generator I do indeed have
that so that way we can have something
constantly making power and it's over
here in the shitty area and that's
connected to the power grid and then
everything can have power at least we
don't have to worry about people
constantly running for power because
when they run they consume more oxygen
and they breathe more carbon dioxide and
they eat more food it's all just bad
news bears so just everybody get to bed
does anybody not have a bed in the
uncomfortable space prison is anybody
not stressed in the uncomfortable spaces
for some reason nori nori is really good
about managing stress I can't even
believe it but nori is just a champ
Norris a champ
she just deals with stress so well
so they're gonna build a coal generator
and then we're always gonna have coal I
may need to put a gas pump on that I
don't know it may pump out contaminated
oxygen again I don't know but so long as
it's something we'll have something
there oh god damn it with the repairs
yeah because then hopefully people don't
have to worry god damn finish it finish
it finish it finish it finish it come on
finish it finish the bear older somebody
finished the PAL man I should just I
should just get rid of that because that
is that is a burden for people to get
across come on almost there almost era
come on mozzarella oh come on let's
build a tile there so people can stop
falling down every single time all right
come on just a little more just a little
more guys just a little more there we go
okay it's done all right capitalization
is number nine so that's gonna get we
have tons of coal I know we have tons of
coal we've got where is it consumable or
coal we got tons of coal we got oodles
of coal so we're not hurting for coal
here and there's definitely more cool
around the area so we can get that going
and no one breaks it looks fine I don't
know why the buyers are Stiller's not
doing its thing but it's not doing its
thing does this not have coal in it
somebody get it coal
somebody get a goddamn coal anybody at
any time can get it some coal I've got
too many things priority 9 I need to
baseline everything to priority 5 just
reset it just get a solid reset on
everything
god dammit they didn't get it cold they
do not get it cold why did they not get
it cold I don't know maybe they can tell
me oh my god why is that not connected
why is that not connected oh my god no
did I do that oh I did that didn't I
okay I'm connecting some algae
deoxidizers up here so hopefully we can
take care of this I mean this one air
deodorizer is taking care of some of the
contaminated oxygen and thankfully the
contaminated oxygen is something that's
breathable I mean they're all sick
anyway so why not
why is no one getting a goddamn coal
just get it so freaking cold are you
kidding me are you kidding me oh Jesus
we're running out of algae God we got to
get more just gotta you just have to
have more slime we got more slime please
please just for the love of God get it
cold and then everyone is breaking
everything it's just someone please get
it cold why is this so hard all right
what I'm gonna do now is I'm gonna try
to get him better food because I think
that's definitely gonna help him but the
problem is everyone is so unbelievably
like non-productive I don't want to call
them lazy but they're just
non-productive this coal generator still
has not gotten cold even though it's at
priority 9 I have no idea why I'm
assuming it's just because every battery
is full and they're just doing fine
without it but III have no idea so I'm
gonna get these fill these with meal
wood cuz that way we'll have a good bit
of food there
we'll have meal wood to go they'll be
doing their thing and hopefully they can
focus on that instead of worrying about
eating mush bars anymore it's gonna be a
while before they're able to be you know
harvested but at least they will be
better off than they just were
I think I heard one of them just say
what back I'm sure they'll be looking
forward to meal wood oh boy oh good they
finished that so now they got access to
that water good damn time
seasons why is this not done that annoys
me that that's not done is there
breaking the connection anywhere what
the heck is that all about overheated
whoa it's overheating
how do you under heat something oh I
didn't even know that we had to worry
about cooling really oh oh [ __ ]
hydro fan oh there's a lot of heat down
here oh no does a hydro fan run on water
it uses water ah that's not good I
didn't even realize that heat
dissipation would have to be would be
something that I would have to worry
about I honestly have no idea how in the
hell did we do that I mean obviously
heat rises so that's a bad place to put
it at first but maybe if we maybe if we
give it a way to go up it might just be
a little bit better if we can vent
things upwards then I'm assuming that we
can make it just a little bit nicer for
work so we're gonna have another layer
of this there this layer of this keep
building upwards guys towards the sky
the sky's the limit
oh you damn right it is okay so as you
can see it's starting to take shape in
terms of the planning not quite there in
terms of everything else but at least we
got the plans underway
we're probably gonna want these to be
there's probably gonna want to be a
solid station I think anyway
at least that's my thought process just
to keep things contained just in case
there's something else up there that's
bad ah the coal generators firing away
is it oh good good good e good so 600
watts I don't know how much this
produces much does it produce probably a
good amount I don't know how it does
compared to the other one but we're
completely out of power so hopefully it
does a little more than nothing
that'd be nice we still connected did
anything get broken that's a little wait
why is that oh god no oh god no why is
that been okay alright well that's there
apparently that didn't need to get built
and apparently we're so big that things
are starting to lag down a little bit
remember this I even though I've been
playing this like for a long time
remember that this game is in fact in
early it's in pre-alpha I've been able
to play up into this point in pre-alpha
that's amazing this game is just I love
this game I haven't been able to say
yeah just because I've been so panicked
at everyone dying but I am having an
amazing time playing this game I love
every bit of this it is so fun like is
legitimately it is so fun just pure and
simple it's fun it's fun to watch these
guys struggle it's fun to watch these
guys through it's fun to help these guys
survive in the only way I know how which
is terribly and it's just it's really
interesting to see how all these things
like come together and how they work and
how they they interconnect and how they
intermingle and hopefully hopefully
they'll survive all this [ __ ] and if
they don't oh my god that's bad but you
know it's just it's really cool
oh so that that emits carbon dioxide
that's dangerous but at least it's
providing a lot of power it's providing
a lot of powers so we have that and
everyone's doing their thing so that's
good
so it's bad that that that does carbon
dioxide but at least it's over in the
contained area not in here which is
still not doing too good but it's doing
okay
oh well apparently that's pumping out
oxygen now so that's nice so we must be
getting something from the slime someone
must have scooped up some of this
because there's a lot of slime on the
ground here yeah sweet pending we got a
lot of stuff going on here so that's
gonna be whoa what Goris what what just
happened Norris how did you get trapped
in there Norris what the hell Doris what
the hell happened to you oh Jesus
Nora still do that you crazy chorus
Oh Doris I'm sorry I didn't mean for
that to happen to you holy [ __ ] Doris
alright then anyway so they're
continuing on their spree we need to
make some doors here let's uh this here
this year this we're all doors man they
take destroy orders very seriously they
destroy quick okay hopefully that's
gonna allow the heat to drop down from
there and then vent upwards so that it
gets hotter up here even though for some
reason this is 28 and this is still
overheated the air around it isn't that
warm over there oh we need a lot more
algae can I prioritize the sweep egde
and they don't take sweep orders with
priority oh they did oh they go god they
did oh [ __ ] that did work
you should still be priority 9 new
person welcome to hell
stinky stinky I like stinky I want
stinky he doesn't seem like a very good
guy because it's got two negative traits
but I'm gonna take him anyway come on in
stinky you might be my new favorite
stinky hey stinky how you doing you
feeling good by thinkI okay so they're
sweeping up there these are not pumping
they're awaiting delivery but that's
okay these are still stifled but at
least the air around it is not too hot I
don't know where we got all this
contaminated oxygen in here from it
should be relatively closed off this
isn't even through oh there's a hole
there I guess make that at least
everyone's so busy that they seem to
have forgotten their stress which will
eventually go down maybe somehow
probably not how wait a minute whoa wait
whoa whoa
there was a puffed in here good the
puffs get out or the puffs go the puffed
escape I don't know I don't know if the
puffed escaped or not okay I'm gonna go
a little bit longer on this episode just
because I want to make sure that things
actually get done oh hey what's
happening with you okay good job you
fell oh man that puffed escape or did
someone kill it did someone lash out at
the puffed and kill it that'd be
horrible okay do I want to flood
everybody and just shunt contaminated
water down there that's something that's
an option probably oh this is how
because there's big holes in everything
I'm doing oh and this is still here
jeezum I didn't even realize that that
was a hole that's been there the entire
time
oops [ __ ] whoops I would love someone
to compare these this base to someone
who actually knows how to play the game
because this is a cot damn nightmare
this is obviously a horrible nightmare
that no one wants to be a part of and
yet here we are in the nightmare good as
good as good as now having a good time
mmm all right so everyone's that guy
what is that guy doing here stinkies
passing out and also starving began
Talbot he cannot sleep
oh he's smelling Otto stinky is bothered
by a putrid odor from Otto oh that's so
sad for you and I'm gonna make a bold
move here because I feel like I need to
make a bold move or else nothing is
gonna happen so here's the deal exactly
what I build over here I'm gonna build
over there except this time it's going
to be unleashing a torrent of water
unlike so this is gonna suck for a lot
of people and this might ruin absolutely
everything that I do but I need
something's got to change here and I'm
just starting to get enough oxygen here
but then everyone keeps breaking the
oxygen things just as soon as they get
repaired so I need slime lots of it I
cleared out this which got me just
enough algae to be able to rejuvenate
everything and just start to make
everything at least clean but other than
that I gotta make a move here so what I
got to do is I just got to make just
qoodles and noodles and Kaboodle's of
maybe maybe maybe that's better maybe I
should keep it contained to here and
then just do it through this and then
keep keep the wall separated and so this
way this way I make this way I don't
need to make flooring I can just dig up
to four across all the way up through
here and then four across all the way
through here so long as I keep it
contained it shouldn't be too much of a
problem and then they sure do love to
dig so I'm just gonna assume that
they're gonna do this pretty post taste
the man is so nice just to get a little
bit of algae and then to be able to help
people out like that because it's
amazing how much cleaner it looks
already just from the little bit the
little bit of oxygen production that was
pumped out by that just the littlest bit
then gone in a flash
but at least the terrariums are back up
from that will be up for a little bit
anyway so they're gonna start doing that
stuff I'm going to go ahead and make
another like accessible route to it just
to have that there that's a thing at
least okay look at that it's beautiful
you get algae you get oxygen it's
suddenly clean who would have thought
who'da thunk tit huh who'd have thunk
that we would be able to get oxygen like
that oh so easily what do you know
welcome it's slightly less hell that it
was before mouth-breather we don't need
that yokel this is fine you're you look
good I don't need another destructive
stress response er I'll take the I'll
take bubbles hey bubbles come on in I
know it sucks here I know I need to make
more beds I think okay but they're
digging that out oh please don't unleash
that please there we go
okay so they're doing that thing I don't
think they can reach that that's what
that is okay so we're gonna cancel so
they can only go to across for the the
thingamabob er so we're only gonna go to
and just go up for now nice you're
looking good guys you're looking good
look at this we actually have some
oxygen I can't believe it is there any
more algae here there is just a bit
though dig that out alright I'm
literally getting down to the last tiny
bits of algae and that's that's just
about it that's just about all I got
maybe yeah small one there and there
good great alright go for that one I
mean obviously people are still gonna be
stressed for a long time but at least
with clean air hopefully it'll start to
go down
and then with clean air hopefully the
temperature will go down here yeah it
looks like it's already lower ambiently
so hopefully these will be able to go
down you know you could stop breaking
that at any time but this is good this
is actually good believe it or not this
looks better than it just did so um I
think this is a good place to stop for
this episode here because I'm doing good
I'm doing it this is this is
legitimately habbo lag it's starting to
get a little intense II oh no it's just
frozen I positive this is this good it's
starting to look better these oxidizers
are going we're repairing what we can
the stress oddly enough is going down
not everyone's at 100% so we're doing it
so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know how i'm doing the
comments below as always I will see you
in the next video
[Music]